hello everyone i'm very happy to talk to
you about
the webinar today on effective rna
extraction
so if we take a look to the agenda
we are going to first have a quick
introduction about covid19
uh i will talk then about what are the
current diagnostic technologies
and especially relation in relation with
the current pandemic that we are
suffering
then chris nori we talked to you about
you know our our effective iron
instruction
that we have developed and finally we
will end with a wider portfolio
of technologies that we have around
copied 19.
so we put this slide
together just few days ago
and already the numbers are
much higher today
when this whole thing started on
[Music]
in march for
where we are based in europe we
saw this becoming more or more of a
global issue and we in
a sativa on the molecular diagnostic
side
we are normally behind a number of the
of the diagnostic kits around the globe
with our magnetic beads
our ingredients like the poly a
nucleotides and other
but in this case we thought we
we need to do something more in my
particular case
i am from the north of spain from
pamplona
and as you know in spain the the
virus really started very very hard
during the month of march and i could
see uh my
my mother who is a pharmacist who um
was still going at her 73 year old with
her gloves and her mask
uh to the pharmacy to help as many
people as she could
and with the risk that that will entail
and
seeing that i really could not stay just
there and do
nothing more than normal and the same
goes with with my team
so we thought to uh really work very
hard and uh
and developed the solution that we'll be
presenting today
so when just to get started on
on the terminology so
as you know coronavirus is uh
where covidantine is a new coronavirus
that has very similar symptoms in a way
to the regular
uh kind of flu uh but it also has some
very specific
symptoms like the loss of face to smell
the dry cough
the shortening of breasts that can
really have very little consequences
and but just to be clear in the
terminology
covid19 is that is the disease
it caused by the such copy 2 that was
detected first on the on the who by
province in china and it's also referred
as coronavirus or nobel coronavirus
and it is a rna virus
and has a cochlear structure where the
rna is inside
with these spike proteins on the surface
which is
depicted in the in the in the picture in
in red and orange
and those are the the ones that are that
are
the device uses to to to go into in and
attack the cell
and being the type of virus that it is
it copy itself straight away and
therefore expand
much faster
so now that we have talked about the
basic terminology around the virus
let's talk now about what are the
current diagnostic technologies
to detect the virus so
there if we look into type of
diagnostics relate to kobit 19
there's two main branches that you can
see in the diagram
in the in the screen right now you can
either look or what is happening the
immune response
to your body to the virus which
is basically you're using blood and
you're looking for antibodies
and for that you would use a lateral
flow or a chemical luminescence say
i would say that prolateral flow is much
more common
or you can look for the virus and if we
look at your virus you can either look
towards the uh the proteins the spike
proteins that were seen or antigen
that were seen in the in the graph in
the in the page before
and and for that you will use a lateral
flow time of test
if you are looking for the actual a val
rna what is inside of the um
of the virus then you are going to use a
molecular type of test that will be
an arctic qpcr
there are other techniques as the lamp
but i will not talk to you
about it in this presentation because
it's much less
common both
the if you're trying to detect the virus
which is what you do
when you try to contain an outbreak like
the one we're suffering
you are going to try to look for the
virus and
both the lateral flow and the rtq pcr
has its pros and cons
for what we thought when we talk about
the lateral flow the challenge there
is that the antibody range is very wide
which means that it takes normally much
longer
to to find an accurate
or sensible test that really will give
you the right result
also it's always challenging uh with
the non-speed binding or crystal
reactivity
to get really a accurate test
on its favor it is really really uh
fast it takes really not long to kind of
do a performance test
and it's much less expensive on the
other side
the rtq pcr it tends to be more
expensive than lateral flow
but very quickly after the outbreak in
uh
in china there were already some tests
because those
can be developed much faster also
because you're looking for a vital rna
in general the sensitivity tends to be a
more accurate than the lateral flow so i
will say
that if you want to make sure if you
have the virus or not
you will go for the rtpcr
now let's look a bit more closely what
is the workflow
for the rtpcr so
you have mainly three steps
you have the sample collection you have
the viral purification
viral learning purification and then you
have the rtpcr amplification
so let's go step by step
so in the sample collection you have
many ways to get the sample
the swap on respiratory tract is really
the gold standard
and that's the one that is most follow
around the globe
now when you go to the vital rna
purification the first thing you want to
do
is to inactivate the virus to avoid any
any
anyone taking the disease this can be
done
through the transform media such as the
prime store
which uh christina will talk to you a
bit more later from longhorn
or it can also be done through a lysis
buffer
in the instruction key
then the extraction can be done either
through
columns which is the more
traditional way of doing or through
magnetic which are getting
a lot of traction since it allows to
really
increase the the throughput and with
a lot of automation now talking on
automation you have to differentiate
between basically two type of systems
there are plenty other
you have systems that are closed and
systems that are open
the closed systems have a lot of
advantages is
like the apple
ecosystem everything works very well
together
but we have some disadvantages
especially in these pandemic times
that when the supplier of that closed
system
has trouble with their supply chain
then you cannot go anywhere else so
that's just some thought on the
automation
finally when we talk about the rt pcr
amplification
this can basically be one step or two
steps
the the only difference between both of
them is that in the one step
both the rt enzyme and the attack
polymerase will be in one single tube
and you will use temperature to activate
one or the other
we will say that in most of the cases
the the trending market
is going toward the one step because
it's a much a simpler process
now how we said that let's go more in
detail and i passed that to chris norris
to talk more
about our solution
hello everyone it's a pleasure to be
joining you on this webinar today
as gabrielle mentioned this covet
pandemic is touching all of us
personally
for myself my wife is working as a nurse
on the itu unit
so she is seeing the patients firsthand
and the criticality of testing and
understanding whether the patients are
infected or not
really helps in terms of the medical
staff being able to make decisions then
about ongoing treatment
so what i'd like to do in this section
of the talk is talk a little bit more
about the details
behind the kit and the methods of using
it
so just first to carry on from what
gabrielle was saying about the test that
he used primarily for the
identification of the virus it's largely
a one-step
rt-pcr action which is essential for the
extraction first of the rna
you then move on to the rt step it goes
into a
master mix in a plate for the pcr
reaction
that reaction amplifies the dna
molecules
and we can see this happening on a
thermocyclist system
and then we can report the result to a
clinician
in this case we have the sars cov2
genome that represents the virus as we
as was mentioned
we add the specific primers and probes
that are required for detection of that
particular virus
in our examples we're using the engine
but we'll talk about that a little bit
later
the aliquot is then put into the the pcr
plate together with that master mix and
the enzymes
and allows it to run through the
amplification program
you have a specific sequence probe
that is quenched and when the sequence
is amplified that probe is able to
bind to the sequence and generate a
fluorescent signal
that fluorescent signal is then
identified
as the cycles are carried out for the
pcr reaction
and its detection of that ct value
is allowed to make the decision as to
whether the virus is present or not
and generally speaking anywhere above 30
ct cycles is considered a
positive result uh and under 40.
and that can be then discussed with the
clinician
again just to highlight that a little
bit more the rna that we use is
extracted
from the from the sample we use an
aliquot then to complete the rt step
and then it goes into the pcr action
where the replication occurs
and it uses a temperature profile as
shown above in this slide
allowing for thousands and millions of
the copies of the
fragment to be generated and with the
probe present to give the highest
fluorescent signals
so let's talk a little bit more about
our extraction kit this is the first
step in the process that was mentioned
uh previously
the cera extractor kit provides a simple
and rapid method for
the isolation of the viral rna
it's based on our silica beads
the ceracil beads which are silica
coated magnetic particles
and the chemistry has been optimized for
the selective binding of rna and dna
and generally we've been using this with
swab samples
mimicked to be like a real sample
it's also compatible with automation so
it allows for high throughput use
for many samples to be measured all at
the same time
and the resulting nucleic acid can be
used for the downstream processing
both in pcr assays or other applications
such as next-gen sequencing
to delve into it a little bit deeper as
mentioned we have the silica beads
we don't use carrier rna in the protocol
which allows for reproduct reproducible
yields and sensitivity of detection
we've tested the protocol both in manual
and high throughput automated systems
and that allows us for allows for high
throughput processing of samples we can
also be flexible on the amount of sample
used
we've tested between 100 microliters and
400 microliters
so it's scalable for the user
the protocol can be completed in around
30 minutes or less
so it's a rapid extraction process that
does not delay the
the generation of the test result
and we've also been able to show that
it's compatible with use with a number
of different sample types
and can go on to be used in a number of
different analytical
processes following
taking a slightly more detailed look at
the protocol
we start off with a sample which is
often in transport media which the swabs
has been collected in
to that we add our lysis binding reagent
the beads and also optionally protein hk
and run an incubation we then pull the
beads to the side of the tube using a
magnet
and the rna in the dna has been able to
bind to those beads
and we remove the rest of the solution
that's no longer required
we then carry out a couple of wash steps
and the principle is the same
first we add the wash buffer mix it with
the beads
again pull the beads to the side of the
tube and remove the solution
the second wash is with 80 ethanol again
added to the tube
mixed with the beads we pull the beads
to the side of the tube
and remove the solution the final step
then is the evil
illusion of the rna from the beads
here we add the illusion buffer or the
nuclease-free water that we're using
again mix with the beads pull the beads
to the side of the tube
and this time the rna is now in the
solution and that rna solution can be
removed to a clean tube
and be used for the onward processing
steps
so next what i'd like to show is some of
the performance data that we've
generated with the kit
to indicate that it's appropriate for
the extraction of the viral
rna from patient samples
so the first experiment we did was to
look at the recovery of a synthetic rna
species essentially what we have here is
a
synthetic rna containing the n-gene
it's been spiked into transport media
our optimized protocol was carried out
with prime store
mtm media from longhorn vaccines and
diagnostics
in addition we added three times 10 to
the five gercat cells to mimic a
clinical type sample
which would have the presence of cells
also
we then performed the extraction on 200
microliters of sample containing the rna
at the copies per microliter shown in
the graphs
the detection is then performed by the
one step rtpcr reaction
using the path one-step reagents from
thermo-fissure
and a copic 19 primer set
n1 n2 and n3 from integrated dna
technologies
we also use rna's p as a control
and then we look at the ct value
observed to indicate the detection of
rna
both attack path and the end primer sets
used
are those recommended by cdc in some of
their guidelines
so in this first experiment you can see
we've added 110
and one copy per microliter of the three
primers
and we can get detection of all three
concentrations
effectively using the pcr reaction
for the table on the right hand side we
have simply compared that to the results
that have been quoted in the cdc
uh publications as the sensitivity of
this type of
application and what we see is that our
serra extractor kit
with the one step prt pcr reaction
gives us comparable types of ct values
indicating that our kit is sensitive
enough for the detection of the virus
using the synthetic rna as our model
in the second reaction we've done a
direct comparison between the serra
extractor
virus extraction kit and the kia mini
loot
virus spin extraction process
this again is one that is ex recommended
by the cdc
in their guidelines and what we can see
is that for all three primer sets
and for the p rnasp gene we're getting
equivalent
ct values for all of the different
concentrations of the
synthetic rna added to the solutions
giving us a good indication that our kid
has the right sensitivity for this type
of application
and equivalent to the kits that are
recommended by ctc for field use
in our next experiment we wanted to test
the ability of an automated system to
run the protocol
so what we have done here is compare
that with a manual protocol side by side
again we've used synthetic rna
at 1100 and one copy per microliter
and we've used the manual protocol as
described previously
and also the kingfisher system to
replicate
an automated platform what you can see
again is that for all three primer sets
n1n2 and n3
had all three of the concentrations
tested
together with the rna's p gene as the
control gives
more or less equivalent performance
using the automated protocol
some of the elements in on the automated
system are not able to replicate the
full manual protocol so as you can see
there are some slightly
uh higher ct values for the automated
protocol but all of them
fall within the detection rate that is
suitable for detection of the virus
and gives a positive result for all of
the concentrations tested
this enables the test to be run at much
higher throughput
and with much larger sample numbers for
any
testing service or center
in this next experiment we also looked
at
the comparison between an automated and
a manual protocol
but this time for a different collection
media as mentioned previously the
previous slides
were done with prime store mtm
these experiments were done with kotem
kopanu tm collection
media and again you can see that both
the manual
and the automated protocols give
comparable results
for all three primer sets and the rnasp
control
and again give acceptable ct values at
at least down to 10 copies per
microliter
again showing the application of this
extraction method
from different transport media
in the final experiment we wanted to try
out
some more virus-like particles
so these are some synthetic viral
particles
from serocare they're a symbios-like
virus but containing the
sars cov2 gene sequences again for the
end gene and covering the n1n2 and n3
primers
again we tried this in a manual and an
automated protocol
and this was carried out at 2.5 copies
per microliter of the viral particle
we spiked the vario particle into the
transport media in the same way as
described above
and in this example we're using the
copan transport media again
and what you can see again is we get
both acceptable ct values for the
detection of the virus
and also very comparative values between
the manual on the automated protocol
so again here we believe that we're
showing relevance to the virustype
particles
and the ability of the kit to extract
from from that type of material
so just to complete in summary
the cell extractor virus pathogen kit we
believe
is appropriate for high throughput
nucleic acid extraction from a variety
of pathogen types in our experiments and
our testing we primarily focused on the
sars cof2 virus
as mentioned by gabrielle it's really
the the topic of the moment and where
our primary focus has been
we've been able to demonstrate a range
of sample types
but again our main focus has been on
swabs collected into universal transport
media
that is currently being used for much of
the testing in in the pandemic
areas we get reproducible
and good sensitivity yields when we run
the kit
and this allows us for for detection at
good sensitivity levels
and appropriate ct values we've
demonstrated that we can
perform the assay both in manual and
automated format
which means that it's compatible with
the higher throughput processing steps
and large sample numbers we have
flexibility in terms of the sample
volume
and the com the procedure is quick and
can be completed in
around 30 minutes or less allowing again
for a good number of sample processing
to be carried out and with that i'd hand
you back to
gabrielle to finish off the presentation
thanks chris so just to finalize
i'm going to talk to you very quickly
about what other
technologies we have in our portfolio
that can help
a covenant in or on one way or another
so in this in this slide we have
divided between sample preparation which
is common to all the processes
and then in terms of detection it can be
done through rtq pcr
which was talking at the beginning of
this presentation
and then it also can be done through
sequencing then this
as you see at the bottom there's some
customized solutions and i will mention
them
briefly in in one second so if we look
to sample preparation on top of this uh
of this kit we have our wide range of
magnet beads like the ceramic beads
the uh stressed mac a bit as well
and then other components that have been
very very popular like the
polya which is an enhancer or the
sensitivity of what you have a
small amounts of rna and as well as the
column base
with our early spin columns
then we go to detection we have
nucleotides we have back polymerase we
have side eyes as well
excited can also be used as part of the
the manufacturing process of some of the
kit
and finally in the sequencing side we
have a wide range of
products that can help the special team
i will highlight
in here our stella max select which is
the size selection
and pc hacking up ready to go reagent
based on our ceramic
finally on our customized solutions and
we have
mainly in this covenant team we have
seen a lot of
uptake on our lifestyle technology which
is a technology that allows to take
reagents that are
need to be stored at a very negative
temperatures
and thanks to our technology of life the
fluidization
some of our excipients we're able to to
make them room temperatures table and we
do this
in a in a custom by customer so we
we actually do that with our customers
reagents
and we have some public announcements
lately with a company called gene drive
but we have many other projects going on
with covet 19. then we
we can do formulation changes to any of
the products to customize
the the products for example we are
working with some
customers to uh to talk about the
customizing to their needs
our structa virus and pathogen kit
and then also we do contract
manufacturing or any of the parts of the
process
and as i was talking on on the
sequencing there's a full range of
products to help the ngs workflow
i would not stop any of these because i
i think they are very well mentioned the
previous slide
but it doesn't it was a good for for
your reference
so just to summarize uh you know
we think we can really uh provide a lot
of
solutions to these uh this crisis
and i really hope you enjoyed this
presentation and we look forward to
hearing from you
and now to your questions thank you very
much